Madame Mademoiselle Monsieur bonjour la
campagne électorale officielle
officielle est terminée depuis hier soir
minuit il n'y aura donc plus de réunions
aujourd'hui il n'y a plus forte raison
demain deuxième tour de l'élection
présidentielle les deux candidats ont
donc profité de la dernière journée de
campagne pour faire un véritable
marathon François Mitterrand s'est rendu
successivement à Épinal Mulhouse et
Nantes sur place Bruno Masure
lorsque François Mitterrand arrive déjà
très en retard à Mulhouse la grande
salle du palais des sports où sont
rassemblés 8 à 10 000 personnes
échauffées par Michel Rocard le candidat
attendra patiemment la fin du discours
de celui qui fut son rival avant de
monter lui-même à la tribune visiblement
affecté par les attaques sur son action
pendant la guerre François Mitterrand
rappelle longuement ses activités de
résistance et décoration et note que
lors de la campagne de 65 le général de
Gaulle lui-même n'a jamais mis en cause
son action dans la résistance il a fallu
pour cela dit-il attendre que la race
des collaborateurs s'en mêle
un saut en avion et c'est Nantes l'étape
finale d'un marathon de deux mois 20 à
30 000 personnes attendent le candidat
le dernier discours sera le plus court
François Mitterrand entend ne pas
dépasser minuit et il est près de 11h30
en une demi-heure François Mitterrand va
donc résumer les grands thèmes de sa
campagne se présentaient comme l'homme
qui sera rassemblé les Français face au
maître de l'argent qui ont choisi de
jouer de la peur et du mensonge Giscard
dit qu'il a changé il vous demande de
lui faire confiance une nouvelle fois
comme si le 1er septennat était pour
Giscard et le second pour destin ironise
François Mitterrand qui résume la
campagne en une comédie en 5 actes 5 et
maths le face à face
le candidat sortant joue les professeurs
rôle de composition
j'étais en face je voulais dire l'autre
soir
en face d'un conducteur qui avait mis la
voiture dans le fossé mais qui
prétendait me faire repasser mon permis
de conduire je l'entends encore me
demander
quel est le cours du marc
et j'avais c'est une confidence un peu
tardive je vais envie de lui répondre
quel est donc le cours du diamant
maintenant
nous sommes à l'opéra au final le grand
air de la calomnie
au fond il est document le cas échéant
on invente on tronque les textes on
oublie le contexte je le répète je suis
engagé sur le programme que j'ai
présenté pour l'élection présidentielle
mais il n'y a rien dans celle-ci qui
menace les petits
qui menacent aussi bien sur le plan de
la vie quotidienne
les agriculteurs et commerçants les
artisans il n'y a rien qui menace les
petites et moyennes succession au
contraire il n'y a rien qui menace le
logement la retraite des cadres la
médecine et pharmacie ce n'est pas parce
que Monsieur Giscard d'Estaing n'a pas
de programme qu'il est autorisé à
déformer complètement dans le mien
voilà ce que je dis tranquillement au
président sortant je ne donne de leçons
à personne
mais je n'en demande de personnes
je ne demande pas de leçon de morale ni
de leçon de rigueur et je ne demande
surtout pas de leçon sur la France à
celui dont de Gaulle prémonitoire sans
doute disait déjà que son problème
c'était le peuple j'aperçoit partout je
me rends
améliorer tout à l'heure à Épinal cet
après-midi et chaque jour il en va de
même le courant populaire
le rassemblement que j'appelle de mes
vœux il existe il est là
il me permet de dire que nous allons
gagner
voilà il est minuit juste les dés sont
jetés François Mitterrand restera muet
jusque dimanche soir avant de regagner
Paris l'adresse du balcon un dernier
salut à la foule mais c'est dehors qui
scande adieu Giscard et Mitterrand
président